so with the ant-man prelude and the
history of Scott Lang model doesn't give
us a whole backstory that is to say they
don't tell us the childhood of Scott
Lang they don't tell us his teenage
years or his high school years instead
they just really kind of jump into it
the way this story starts off Scott Lang
is basically in jail he's in prison and
it seems as though he's already been
busted for a criminal act and so what he
does is he takes us from this kind of
backstory in terms of why it was he was
put into the circumstance why it is he's
in jail in the first place and what
Marvel tells us here is that Scott Lang
had previously worked for a company
called Vista corporation and what mr.
corporation was doing is they were
basically using a computer algorithm to
skim money off the top or to overcharge
their customers mean that if a good cost
$5 they charge their customers $5.00 or
something like that a fraction of a cent
but over time these numbers would build
up and the result was that the money the
extra money that was being overbilled
was being taken by some of the top
bigwigs and it was being spread around
they were using it for their own
personal game and so when Scott Lang had
learned about this he had basically cut
the algorithm but the problem here was
at the CEO who is one of the people that
was making money off of this scam told
him to set it back and so in response to
the fact that the company was doing
something illegal what Scott Lang
basically did is he went to human
resources and he was basically a
whistleblower he told Human Resources
what it was it was going on he told them
that the company was skimming money but
as it appears to us or at least the
indication seems to be that either the
company itself had basically shut out
Scott Lang regardless of the intentions
of human resources to actually right
this wrong or it seems to be the case of
human resources was in on the act
but regardless Scott Lang is basically
fired and his name is if smear through
the tabloids he's basically lost his
credibility and so the problem here for
Scott Lang is that he has a daughter
Cassie and he's also married and so he
wants to basically provide for his
family to be able to give them the kind
of I guess the kind of foundation they
need in order to live a satisfying life
for the other half of this is that he
wants to get back at this company that's
stealing people are stealing from people
and what seems to happen here is his
wife seems to give us this indication of
what it was that he used to engage in
before all of this started in the sense
that he was a criminal prior to becoming
a legitimate job but
Vista corporation but that his criminal
lifestyle seemed to be stealing from
crooks a Robin Hood so to speak where he
was stealing from the rich and giving
back to the poor and so the deal that
had been struck between the two of them
was that once caste the daughter of
Scott Lang came into the world the Scott
Lang would leave all of that behind but
for Scott Lane this is something
something just too big to ignore it
really just seems impossible for him to
walk away from it and so what he does is
he basically devises this plan and the
plan that he asked comes in a couple
stages the first stage is to go to
Visser corporation itself and actually
take all the money that's being a that's
being transferred to the to the top
members of the company to those who were
skimming from the company and to
basically transfer all that money back
to the people they over build the second
thing was to basically travel to the
actual home of his CEO and to
essentially trash the place and a Scott
Lang tells us this is where he made his
mistake that rather than simply just
stealing the jewels of the CEOs wife
rather than simply just doing a little
bit of damage here and there that he got
whelmed he was overwhelmed he got caught
up in this situation and the result was
that he was arrested by the police and
he was taken to jail which gave us his
current situation now again this is a
prelude this is a lead-up to how the
film is initially just going to kick off
and so the problem here is that well we
don't really know anything other than
this what we can presume is that when
the film begins this is where it'll
start with him being in a fight in
prison and and just kind of going
forward from there with that being said
I know this is a short video but
Marvel's really really kind of skims it
when they give us these pre lewd videos
it'll go very in-depth here they just
kind of resent us a handful of
information and just sort of go from
there so with that being said I will
catch you guys later peace